welcome everyone to floor gang flagon
fluorine fluorine floggin it's the why
[Music]
I'm excited let's get into this oh did
they publish this oh my god
YouTube start purify kicks dot this is a
lie I never did this actually this is
fair well played
there are no accidents whoops it was an
accident
I don't know if which video will come
out first but I did it while recording
so you there was no it was accident
people like oh there's a conspiracy he's
doing it to promote black ops no I'm
just an idiot okay every conspiracy
around me can be summarized I'm an idiot
like I was gonna private it right away
as soon as I noticed but people loved
the video so I was like oh chant damn
I'm glad I didn't say anything bad in it
things were different ten years ago
remember you could say stuff I remember
uh whoa
boots is back down the line so I'm
pushing myself god damn dude that's
cooler than my setup that's not fair
this is [ __ ]
what is this IKEA Mike come on then very
epic I like it
we know Peter price profile pictures of
Rio from nevermind crybaby but why this
specific anime it's because it's in the
very last episode the main character has
no likes okay massive spoiler guys this
conspiracy is actually true you figured
me out congratulations MGM my case floor
game confirm
logging I knew it F deep down deep down
down everyone floor game everyone will
be flow gay oh he said it he said the
thing wait I gotta see evidence I don't
believe it Tesla oliseh floor gang
confirm we're a peaceful religion
everyone will join and anyone that
doesn't will die okay I'm not
threatening but subscribe bail
notification come on 11% and Leben %
disgraceful felix chains are useless
chains what can you actually do that you
can't do that light the salt ceiling
gang cringe Oh My gods
whenever I see a ceiling that's my
reaction what go some ceilings spiders
no one likes spiders they're for
stealing bad ceiling paint we should
just get rid of them what's the point
oh god damn move aside yo yo gang it's
slinky game slinky gang damn oh my god
dude that's so cool
I can do that just give me a couple
minutes practice all right let me just
buy a slinky Thor god of lightning
I remain multi billionaire with the suit
worth billions Hulk um damn best fan art
I've seen today
good job big pay P Galax tag on I'm a
little aroused I'd be lying if I said I
wasn't you can smash like I know you are
too I'm not threatening but I will throw
these tambourine all you flinched cringe
everyone 2020 can't get worse me
Thanos new snap famous flora gang
confirmed guys I knew it no no no Sweden
isn't famous for anything meatballs
Spotify Abba IKEA Beauty pine floor game
minecraft damn
first aid kit you're welcome saves life
the wrench you're welcome
saves life the zip you're welcome
PPP joke VP joke
lyin PT PI I'm sorry in advance oh my
god
oh my god you finally figured me out huh
you finally I benefit you get it like a
good spin on it this would be like razor
sharp and just I think that's what the
tambourine was invented for I'm pretty
sure yeah I'm sure
meat bites into a burger everything on
the other side of the burger Oh bro I
finished Jojo
start this crusader and I'm so sad I was
enjoying it so much that was the most
satisfying anime ever and then I said
big VP sure did he's crying he's small
peepee I like how you squeeze Ricardo
nice and Ducote peopIe billion percent
off that's a great price his team in
Call of Duty PewDiePie
I watched through the other videos cuz I
was curious
thank God like it was a decent gameplay
I don't think they were all good like
that one it's so funny what did I say in
the video in case you're not up to speed
I accidentally I want I don't want to
say that my team was mates were bad but
they died of the guy in line I guess
they had a bad day or so funny man dude
like this took me back so hard I'm just
like damn going from that little sweet
in that tiny flight to where I am today
is this unbelievable I could barely
speak English and I'm second-guessing
every word I say crazy dude thank you
for watch I'm just so humbled by it just
like gave me so much perspective pip I
imagine simple to a girl with dyed hair
oh no
no I would seem for all of them mm
that's not Laurie gang oh yeah floor get
merge epic you can be comfy too happy
ten years anniversary thank you guys
thank you when I first hit I was I am 10
years but now I'm reflecting on it it's
just insane to think about what an
amazing panel I love this style I came
looking for a copper and I found gold
alright in another 10 years I'll publish
another one of these that'd be great
dude I'm like an entirely different
person it's just crazy to think about
after three years they still have this
graffiti behind my school it's behind
your school that's crazy
don't show this do Marzia do not show
this to what's yeah this one time I was
drunk
okay guys you don't have to keep posting
it they call me a fool I called them
ceiling game cringe absolute cringe walk
to a friend's house bro is that a flip
in ceiling bro I bring a sage to with me
every house I ain't there damn you what
does [ __ ] curse you perry I don't get it
stop
I haven't watched it yet I will I will I
will I promise is promise
oh god that's not that's all these no
God that's all this llama is gonna be
about next week god damn it no like I
can do this huh if I hold the fake one
be monetized but I can do this you know
exactly what I mean
sitting on the second floor it doesn't
mean that Felix is stealing Hank it just
means that he's blowing on another lever
think I must have been the ceiling in me
teacher can some strong voice help me
carry these chairs me and the boys
Oh floor Hank 20% muscle increase
subscribe now Felix I see you guys
tomorrow doesn't upload for two days
straight the entire floor again I feel
heart crack this is sus I mix it up
sometimes I'm sorry
how many Koreans in their thirties play
Minecraft okay Pete by working on it
good now we just need a landmass didn't
eat wheat something I mean he tweeted a
lot of things stopped we just take a
break from Twitter trust me on this one
yeah just take a break bro minecraft has
amazing legs I knew it oh wait they're
getting minecraft on Tesla's that's
insane
that'd be so cool I was like oh got it
I get it because I was first to see
Felix new video no I was first am it yes
that's right no I was first I was first
side don't even try to make this a big
don't even try to make this amazing that
you're anything thank you RTX off RTX oh
I need to try that I can't believe I
haven't done yet I think it's like in
beta at the moment he can only use
Windows 10 version cringe
that's his cringe at ceiling gang all
right what do we got petition to add
this to the base let's say this man the
quality's almost this gives my bit what
10 out of 10 Ted Ted definitely adding
there that's hilarious amazing black and
red is high when you finally turn 18 and
don't have to set your birthday to 1600
BC when you're creating an account
anymore I always pick a hundred years
they usually never let you I lost my
password once and they were like okay so
what's your age I'm like 30 it says here
you're a hundred and five sorry
marzia we're landing now I'll see you in
the bit if Felix was a pilot alright
this is gonna be top tier landing just
watch
that's flora gang beautiful
come on someone's gonna comment like oh
it's because you're blue no one cares
stop it the loss of fixes physics may
break down at the edge of the universe
we know this futurism cringe fame power
and fat bank account will change almost
anyone Lord clearly I haven't changed
anything from my 10 year old videos what
are you talking about I'm the same I'm
the same guy
the thing is though I'm still as awkward
and weird it's just that I can hide it
through loud noises and screaming oh
where did you learn to dance as well
Ricardo
that's right my wife's boyfriend taught
me what I don't think I ever danced so
much is that nice what do you want to
play Minecraft burger Ricardo says you
have to go to bed early same energy huge
PP energy right there
huge you see I told you that's the joke
I wanted before goddamnit someone drew
this just for the meme nice I respect
that
big PP when your wife boyfriend calls
you big boy
cuz I am screaming floor gang will
instantly gain 50% muscle okay alright I
spent two days made 303 drawings and
took almost 40 pieces of paper making
this but definitely worth it
nice no no no I was gonna go a different
girl I'm surprised let me
I should just put this away I'm sorry
this is getting annoying 10 out of 10
huge peepee well done well done
ah goddamn he's got the is that two
chairs no it isn't whoa whoa how we do
that how we do that you got a tambourine
well done well done my man huge BB
absolutely come on don't be scared of
water
no yeah I may have gone a little
overboard we minecraft and my killing
sprees I apologize I apologize it's my
fault
my bad gamers youtuber yells at sea I
don't yell cringe coca-cola or Pepsi FA
it's been six months it's a simple
question
dude this is just sad what the flip law
answered the damn question shop
coca-cola of course dummy side G fuel is
the answer got alright demoted sorry
right there I didn't want to do this
your daddy will die your mo yeah I
definitely got a report your mum he will
die your puppy will die
I want to make a Jojo reference but I
don't want to spoil it but this is so
sad you know what I mean I cried I cried
goddamn it
you'd say sorry Myers are looking up
guys it's Myers he actually stealing
gang
no we're clear all right what is it only
PewDiePie Minecraft fans veterans will
understand unsubscribe right now if you
didn't get this joke gets new pet animal
likes it becomes mean - it traps it has
fun hurting it accidently only [ __ ]
ain't that Hamas to death how most adder
than that you can't be the biggest
youtuber in Sweden or your home time you
can be the big as youtuber on the street
I remember when he was a bigger youtuber
than me I'm just like actually had no
opinion
I like this videos ceiling gang I mean
picky I'm not gonna force anyone but
just pick your side or you will die
like this man that Anna is this the same
way yes I tell I'm telling me 100%
muscle increases just do it just
subscribe right now
I'm not gonna force you or anything all
right I'm not gonna force anyone to do
anything it would be really kind of you
to subscribe girlfriend will rise up
against you will leave you for a better
man doesn't want you to be in gangs
can't lie to her floor will never rise
up true always stays with you truth it's
literally the gang truth can literally
lie on it
I mean sure you'll get back pains and
but problems and but these are minor
sacrifices to be floor gang fetus
innocent infant cute deceit child
juvenile prio it's me confused teen an
existential either responsible adult
boomer Swedish Eminem flow flow 10%
increase I keep telling you do you guys
see the guy that broke
the deadlift record notice has it eats
on the floor and not the ceiling I rest
my case
that's legit impressive well done men am
i after peopie starts chatting floor
gang and the only time Maya likes me is
in the mornings when I let her like the
rest of my porridge that's the only time
otherwise is like get the flip away from
me get it cuz he has long hair
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha to be fair that
we are flipping matching them very nice
Dave next time can you do a little bit
more pinkish hue that'd be anything oh
that's amazing thank you dirty noodle
soup I don't like your name but I like
your when you pay 399 to be on the floor
very nice he has a lacquered there to
cover his huge peepee well done man
a hundred million Bishan it lets up guys
no next move side let's move on yeah
dolphins have returned to ility
meanwhile in youtube i can't believe it
bumped to all subscribers unbelievable
there must have been a glitch or
something you should not do that
oh my god please clutch please I need
these save me for real that'd be dope
those look hella comfortable makini duty
get it next episode we'll be bringing
back an old friend as you can see I'm
not dead we'll find him I'll do whatever
it takes to find their bang timeless
it's mine please tambourine a hey guy
come here look it's not scared of the
tambourine
ok you see with Pepe see he loves me
you're not scared of the tambourine are
you yeah my floor game Farex
yeah I recommend floor
[Music]
for all guys no frog Ango frog
good job a guy you did it yeah yeah good
job I've never been so proud
imagine having small PP internet that it
took you nine years to upload another
part of your Cod gameplay it was a slow
burner guys petitioned for peers to stop
bullying never he's evil and so is
anyone that hasn't subscribed hit the
bell notification bought all the merch
wait I saw someone that I saw a really
sweet post what was it look at that my
ten years of pretty fight so sweet I
can't believe they all right it seems
like I'm trying to manipulate people I
don't obviously it doesn't matter if you
buy the March or not but it's really
like that's it that's pretty insane
that's cool but girls don't exist
baby huge mash them alright guys thank
you for watching this video
did you have fun again I had fun again
just like thanks for 10 years you know
what [ __ ] it let's do a breakfast here
you go thanks thank you guys
in a world where science knows no
boundaries travel to land where no tuber
has been and explore never-before-seen
landscapes
[Music]
beings that are extinct meet Mayan
actors ancestors who collects patient
items rediscover your favorite
scientifically accurate dinos what will
you create
you